she said that Libs of tick tock spread
lies about the Boston Children's
Hospital providing hysterectomies
however on their own website there was a
video or I should say this there is a
video of a woman from the Boston
Children's Hospital explaining what a
hysterectomy is and they they say on
their website that uh or it's been
reportedly as people have been sharing
they uh provided hysterectomies to
adolescents now AOC doesn't know that or
she's lying uh I guess I'll ask you do
you think she's lying or do you think
she just doesn't know I think she's
saying what she was told to say
I mean it's as simple as that so whether
both whether that yeah whether it's an
outright lie or doesn't want to believe
the truth doesn't want to hear something
else this is what she has heard and that
is what she is regurgitating